you ever do like a Charlie's Angels 3  like what's going on with that it's  funny  um that I just was watching Lucy uh  funny enough who I was texting with this  morning and she was at Comic-Con for  yeah the new uh shazam movie and they  asked her would you do a Charlie's three  and I was on the edge of my seat I would  be surprised if any one of us ever  decreed that we wouldn't be yeah also  don't you think you need a gay Bosley  oh my God you would be the best Bosley  dream roll you Cameron Lucy like that's  it for me that's Holy Trinity I just I  those movies were  everything to me I would I wouldn't yeah  the answer is an emphatic yes I will  always say yes